I better look like a freshly born Gerber
baby if I'm going to be spending $2 million
on anti-aging hacks hey everyone
I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's
Kitchen in today's video we'll be taking a look
at Tech sent to millionaire Brian Johnson's
biohacking longevity blueprint that promises to
turn back the hands of time a huge thank you to
Eric Williamson of unlocked Fitness and Nutrition
who helped me in the research on this video so
if you're looking for any kind of one-on-one
nutrition support for weight loss or Fitness
Nutrition they really are my go-to team so I am
going to be linking all of their links below and
if you are new here definitely don't forget to
Please Subscribe and you can check out my free
Hunger crushing combo ebook and my new protein
ebook in the description below okay so Brian
Johnson aka the most most measured man has spent
$2 million working with a team of 30 doctors to
basically Benjamin Button himself over the past
2 years in results that he made available to the
public he apparently slowed the aging process down
by about 31 years and achieved a body inflammation
level 85% below your average 18-year-old I mean
my te years were not my healthiest so I'm not
sure that that would be a really great Roi for me
personally but definitely impressive nonetheless
and based on his own extensive investment and
success he created a longevity blueprint protocol
that he shares widely online so today we're going
to be unpacking its main components with a little
science andas okay let me hop in here quickly to
tell you about my sponsor today Thrive market so
this time of year is challenging for a lot
of people because we are extra motivated to
eat well and take care of our bodies but the
price of groceries is kind of insane but if
you haven't heard of Thrive Market get excited
because it really has changed the game for me so
Thrive Market is an amazing online membership
based grocery store that aims to make Health
Focus Specialty Products more affordable and
accessible to everyone they are a One-Stop shop
offering foods and snacks eco-friendly kitchen
and cleaning supplies Beauty items supplements
home goods and everything in between most of the
year I live here in Canada but as soon as I get
down to the States I order my Thrive box because
there are just so many amazing products that you
cannot get anywhere else basically you can filter
by over 90 different diets Lifestyles and values
like vegan fair trade gluten-free and more they
also have an amazing selection of sustainable
Seafood wine and nutritious snacks that my kids
love every time I order I discover a handful
of new products that basically become instant
Staples for us and the best part is all items
are less expensive than traditional retail they
price match and me members make back their annual
$60 membership in savings and for whatever reason
you don't Thrive will credit you the difference I
also love their commitment to sustainability so
not only a shipping on orders over $49 free but
everything is delivered with carbon neutral
shipping and from their zero waste warehouses
another thing I really love about Thrive is that
for every paid annual membership the Thrive gives
initiative gives away a free membership to a
lowincome family teacher Andor veteran there's
really so many reasons to feel good about ordering
from Thrive so if you want to save some money on
really unique Health Products this year check
out the link in my description thrivemarket.com
slabby sharp to get 30% off of your first order
and a free gift worth up to $60 biohack number
one is consuming 2250 calories per day with a 10%
calorie deficit so we often see suggestions that
a calorie restricted diet is associated with
longer life because a calorie deficit slows
our metabolism slows cell turnover and increases
autophagy and other processes that help to clean
out damaged and dysfunctional proteins so we see
tons of examples of this in the animal research
where for example monkeys who are given a diet
with a 25% deficit from around adolescence to
the end of their life lived approximately 3 years
or around 11.5% longer if this were translated
into humans and added 11.5% % to the average
American life length of 79 would mean us living
to 88 instead I think this is what the kids these
days would describe as so clutch immediately know
immediately know but alas we're not monkeys so in
human research like the calorie study participants
were prescribed a 25% calorie deficit for 2 years
now a 25% deficit for two whole years is kind of
an insane ask so participants only achieved a
12% deficit on average however even with that
deficit they found reductions in metabolism lower
inflammatory markers and lower cardiovascular
risk factors also those who stuck to the calorie
deficit of at least 10% saw the Aging of their
DNA AKA DNA methylation slowed down by 2 to
3% not quite the effect that we're seeing in
animals like monkeys but if followed over an
entire adult lifetime it could be at least 2
years gained in life so sure caloric restriction
for longevity is supported by evidence it may not
be direct evidence because we can't force people
to restrict their calories until they die but we
do have indicators suggesting that it may help to
reduce risk of early death and early disease that
said you kind of have to decide if being on a
diet until you die is worth maybe getting two
more extra years it's definitely enough for
me though but if you do you want to attempt
a weight loss diet it is imperative that you
are incorporating resistance exercise into your
regimen since humans are a lot more susceptible to
loss of muscle and bone than most animals biohack
number two fast for 16 to 18 hours per day so
we have covered fasting in a lot of detail in
this video right here and if you recall the main
takeaways from my video were a that it can help
some people but not everyone with managing their
weight and B early Tim restricted feeding where
you cut off your feeding window before the
evening can improve insulin sensitivity and
metabolic health and C longer fasts risk muscle
loss if not doing a lot of resistance training
and consuming adequate protein so as with most
diets if it lowers your risk of obesity and or
improves insulin sensitivity it typically lowers
your risk of diseases that may lead to early death
but there are two other unique factors that may
explain how fasting could improve your longevity
in humans one is that it reduces oxidative stress
so this comes back to damaged and dysfunctional
proteins and their role in aging so if we kind of
go back to grade 10 science class oxidative stress
is the creation of molecules that are missing an
electron so these molecules then steal electrons
from important cells leaving those cells damaged
and dysfunctional now oxidative stress is actually
one of the main theories of Aging so anything that
can reduce oxidative stress is said to help and
early Tim restricted feeding so again basically
a fasting window where you eat your breakfast
you have your lunch but you skip dinner likely
reduces that oxidative stress unfortunately this
is not how most people do intermittent fasting
right now the second aspect of fasting that's
associated with longevity is a term that all the
Tik Tok Wellness gurus love to overuse autophagy
so this is the process of those damaged and
dysfunctional protein gen being cleaned up and
removed again the benefit here is with that early
Tim restricted feeding where research suggest that
it increased aoy gene expression by about 10 to
20% a full 36-hour Fast and you might even be able
to bump that up to 20 to 30% now interestingly
these numbers are relatively small when compared
to exercise where we're looking at an over 100%
increase and personally I like exercise a lot
more than not eating for a day and a half now it's
important to know though that there is such thing
as too much autophagy as this published cartoon
depiction from the Journal of autophagy shows we
want to prevent a mess from oxidative stress and
like clean it up but we can actually go too far to
the point that we lose healthy cells and or loss
of important cellular organs like the mitochondria
it's also really important to know that there are
loads of causes of oxid stress like pollutants
obesity processed foods and even psychological
stress and there are a lot of behaviors that can
reduce oxidative stress and increase autophagy
so things like exercise like we discussed sleep
Stress Management and eating a nutrient-dense
diet high in antioxidants intermittent fasting
actually has a relatively small effect and it's
kind of impossible to quantify exactly how much
without teasing out the weight loss benefits but
even if we just compare its autophagy benefits to
those from exercise it's hard to make an argument
that you should skip dinner for the rest of your
life in my opinion anyway so yeah this is up
to you if you decide it's a habit worth your
sanity okay bioh hack number three eating 70 lbs
of vegetables per month okay so 70 lb is a kind
of big scary number I mean I kind of feel bloated
just thinking about it but it ends up working out
to about 2.3 lb or a kilog per day so in a day
that would be equivalent to you consuming one
whole head of celery 10 cups of kale and 3 cups of
chopped sweet potatoes which is definitely still
a lot but if you were super committed it could be
done but does it have to well the American Heart
Association recommends four to five servings
of fruits and vegetable per day based on huge
studies like this and this and as you can see your
risk of early death significantly dein lines once
you reach about five servings of produce and then
after that your return on investment isn't really
that great each serving of vegetables in these
studies is around 80 g so most of the effect
on enhancing longevity is around 400 G that
is less than a pound and far less than 2.3 lb
the for a gram recommendation is also supported
by a modeling study using multiple metaanalysis
that found that 400 G of vegetables per day
would increase the lifespan by about 6 months
if implemented around the age of 45 now while his
suggestion of consuming nearly 2 and a half times
this amount is likely Overkill at least from
a direct longevity standpoint there's really
no risk to this and I can also just understand
wanting to have extra vegetables that are high
in nutrients water and fiber to try to keep him
full if he's trying to constantly maintain a 10%
calorie deficit fiber and volume Rich veg is
really getting key when trying to diet biohack
number four a specific macro ratio of 90% protein
33% carbs and 48% fat this is wildly specific and
must be somehow tailored to his needs based on all
of the excessive medical testing he's had done as
we discussed in our video on Macros protein
is usually the most important macronutrient
to manipulate based on your goals protein protein
protein protein protein protein protein at 90% of
his calories from protein he's getting around
108 gr of protein per day or just under 1.5 g
of protein per kilogram of body weight which is
close to what's ideal for muscle gain a little low
for supporting weight loss but is totally in the
clear for good health now I noticed Brian cited
Stu Phillips paper on Optimum protein intakes for
health which suggests a range of 1.2 to 1.6 G per
kilogram so that maybe explains where he gets his
number now this specific ratios for carbs and fat
however are a lot less important than where you're
getting your carbs and fats from that is we want
whole nutrient dense options which he obviously
seems to fulfill beautifully his diet actually
looks quite close to a Mediterranean style diet
with a variety of colors plenty of fiber and
lots of phytonutrients from plant-based Foods now
we've talked before about how caloric restriction
possibly could add 2 plus years optimal veggie
intake take adding 05 years and Inter fasting
maybe adding sometime too but unlikely to have a
huge effect especially for someone who's already
quite fit and healthy but all of this pales in
comparison to eating a whole food diet rich in
whole greens legumes fruits and veggies research
suggest that this dietary pattern can add an
additional 11.7 years to your life when compared
to a western diet if implemented at age 40 now
that seems like a good Roi finally biohack number
five is taking 100 plus pills per day I'm pretty
good at swallowing pills but I'm feeling just
a little bit gaggy thinking about that I'm not
going to dive into this extensive list of pills
most of which are supplements but some of which
are actually drugs like metformin but there is no
question there are a lot of great supplements on
his list here uh cocoa flavanols ashwagandha DHEA
D3 three even P protein but my general messaging
on supplements is that a simple and streamlined
supplement regimen can really be helpful for a
lot of folks in taking the stress out of eating
perfectly for their goals 100 supplements on the
other hand like I can't think of a more stressful
expensive and logistically intense Endeavor like
you would need a whole supplement Pantry just
to store everything so yeah this is just not
realistic for anyone who isn't a c a million
now obviously his website is a treasure Trove
of intense Data Tracking and protocol details
if you're interested in every test he's run
how much he spent and what his results have been
but outside of his Ode to Sleep which I agree on
is key I didn't see a whole lot of focus on mental
or social health and that's kind of important when
we look at big studies like this one we see that
the number and strength of our relationships are
even better better predictors of our longevity
than anything that is physical health related
same with having a sense of purpose in life and
optimism which can add as much as 12 years to our
lives but with all that said what we can take away
is that from a nutrition perspective at least the
most impactful thing that we can do is choosing
a mostly whole food nutrient-dense diet some
people may find that the trade-off of choric
restriction optimal macros and Inter fasting
worth it for some smaller effects but if it's
impacting your mental health or leading us to not
be able to spend quality time with our family and
friends affecting our happiness and relationships
then it could actually end up having an overall
detrimental effect so that was my professional
opinion my personal opinion is to fasting and
dieting and like get a hobby make a new friend
live your best life there's really not a whole lot
of point in living an extra year or two if you are
anxious and miserable as but on that note thank
you again to Eric Williamson for helping with
today's script I'm leaving a link below for his
information if you're looking for any one-on-one
weight loss or finished nutrition Support also
leave me a comment below on your longevity or
biohacking thoughts subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on aby's kitchen
bye